talking about the san francisco 49ers
the team that had it it was there it was
in the palm of their hands i'm not
trying to rub salt in the wound this is
the reality of ten points with seven
minutes left that play that was called
the
something that's stopping wasps
something something wasp was called and
it was that long throw by patrick
mahomes to tyree kill and that was the
moment where it didn't turn it was that
moment where it was like interesting oh
right right yeah it was yeah it was like
hey if maybe this game isn't over and
then they get the touchdown and then
you know that's when it really started
to accelerate but they they were there i
mean they put in all of the hard work
they climbed the mountain they had one
hand on the summit of everest and got
thrown back to the bottom that's the
reality yeah they did the hard part the
easy part was holding that lead and now
they have to start over again but we
think they will we think they're built
to do it look
chris i've said time and again and and
i'm not just saying this because number
one he's your good friend and number two
i like him as well i think he's the next
belichick i do i think kyle shanahan is
here to stay i think he's gonna be a
great coach i think he's gonna do great
things and you know from time to time if
he says something like uh we needed to
get back to where we were last year and
finish the job and that's kind of
overlooking all the tough work of
getting close to the top of the mountain
yeah let's not presume you're going to
be able to do that again
i'm gonna say that from time to time uh
because i believe it you know bill
belichick is the master of forgetting
about last year good bad otherwise
forget about last year it does not
matter and move on to next year and if
they can do that they can be right back
there near the top of the mountain when
february rolls around yeah no doubt
about it and you know
again i mean listen you know me i agree
with everything you just said there you
know basically other than like hey
kyle's not going to be exactly like bill
belichick you know but when he does make
those comments that you know you like
you say you you kind of perk up and you
go whoa i can't believe the head coach
said that there's always reasoning
behind it it's not like some guy who
just threw out a quote to make the fan
base feel good or whatever and as you
saw there in that clip yeah there's
reasoning about by why he kind of says
that and of course he's not going to
like brush aside the hard work and what
it'll take to get back there but like he
said he wanted to show that hey we were
this close
and you know we just
do one or two things different here and
we win the super bowl easily
and to speak about that last few moments
of the game you know further on in that
interview that two jet wasp at that
point of the game he even says cause i
asked him he goes he went ooh okay like
a little bit like wow all right they're
not out of it that was a big play but he
still felt good about it it was the next
series after when the 49ers went three
and out and the chiefs got the ball back
that's when he told me in the interview
he went uh-oh the momentum has swung
here and we're in trouble and you know
the crazy thing about it is i think
before last year if you told the 49ers
they were up 20 to 10 with six minutes
left in the super bowl they'd be like
we'll sign the deal right now we're
meant to win that game with our
defensive line and our pass rush and all
that
the problem is they came across a guy
that i think is probably the only guy
that could have won that football game
in my homes and that's unfortunate it's
very rarely that the one guy can
overcome to me what is i think the
better team
uh and in the 49ers there's really not a
lot of weakness to the roster and where
very rare mike the first thing i'll say
about them going into 2020 here is you
know yeah they lost to forest buckner
but man it rare that a team in the super
bowl gets two
premium first round picks
and then gets to sign trent
or trade for trent williams a hall of
fame left tackle as they just lost the
super bowl so they quietly improved
their team too which i think a 49ers fan
needs to be excited about
yeah and look we did our rankings to set
the the table for the discussion that
has resulted in one team at a time
working from 32 to number one 49ers come
in at number two we did that before the
season began before the
training camp began
uh i don't know if i was reshuffling the
deck right now what i would do because
i'm concerned about all these injuries i
know and and and it's it's it's
troubling when you hear week to week for
nick bosa who knows if he's going to be
available week one when they take d4
yeah and and uh do they have the depth
beyond the stars are they top heavy or
do they have the next man up that can
that can come in and get it done i mean
whoever you have on the bench
is going to be standing in the shadow of
nick bosa but do you think this is a
team that can withstand injuries and put
in other guys and enroll with backups if
need be and be successful the the the
two areas in which they've had injuries
are now they're big parts of their team
you're right i mean there's no replacing
nick boses or d ford's of the world
there's there's a reason they're getting
paid the money or drafted where they
were because their special special
entities but
i do
if there's a deep part of their football
team it's their defensive line they can
send waves at you that way so to where i
think they can manage that certainly and
then we've seen the injuries at wide
receiver which is concerning and i would
be concerned with most people or most
teams but not as much with shanahan
first off because i do think he's a
genius as far as getting wide receivers
open i mean his ability to scheme and do
those type of things and i still think
there's enough there at the position to
make it happen but they're they're
teetering on a line you're right of man
another injury or two
and holy cow you know they could be
drastically different looking team here
week one and you know i think it goes
back a little bit to you mike where
you've always been spot on about it i
know we've talked about this you know
lynch and shanahan have done a great job
of accumulating psychos and i mean that
within football psychos like guys that
hey it's a walk through and you got to
tell them like hey settle down it's a
walk through stop flying around
hey yeah we're we're we're hitting a
little in practice don't knock his head
off don't drag him to the ground they
got those type of guys and i think
that's led to maybe probably some more
intensity and practice and maybe a few
injuries too
yeah i've used the term roughnecks
instead of psychos but it dawned on me
last year that this is a team that
doesn't need to practice tackling to the
ground they don't need to have intense
sessions where they beat the crap out of
each other because you just flipped the
switch on george kittle you flipped the
switch on nick bo so you flip the switch
on these guys and they're gonna go punch
you in the mouth whenever they get the
chance to do it in a controlled way but
i think that's one of the reasons why
they've been so good and i think that's
what john lynch has brought to balance
out kyle shanahan kyle is very good at
finding the players that fit his
offensive scheme and i think john lynch
is very good at identifying the guys
that remind him of the guys he played
with tampa sure that's a hell of an
experience to bring to the table if
you're a general manager of a football
team working with a head coach who is a
mastermind when it comes to offense so
all that said though i keep looking back
on last season yep yes they had some
games they won easily and they got our
attention early in the season winning at
tampa bay winning at cincinnati
but some of those games were so close
and it came down to a play here a play
there a break here a break there all the
way down to week 17 they could have been
the five seed if the seahawks score on
that final drive of the game and if you
do that drive 10 times five times they
score and five times they don't yeah
can they thread that needle again to get
back to the one seed when you consider
the teams they're going to be playing in
their own division twice per year
seahawks rams cardinals i think the
cardinals are going to be a lot better
and they gave the 49ers fits relatively
speaking in two games last year right i
i this is a team that is going to have
its hands full this year because it had
its hands full last year in emerging as
the 1c yeah and no doubt about it you
know you know the first thing yeah they
won some close tight football games but
you know you can go through a lot of
football teams really and look at that
and go
you know that that was part of their you
know success too the really good
football teams find ways to pull out
those close football games and i think
with that
added to that there's some young pieces
on that team that are going to be better
in year two
and it's really
really year two for jimmy garoppolo
because he got so hurt and you know hurt
so early on in his you know first
complete season there so i expect him to
be better that way and i'll say this
this is the other thing that i'd be
encouraging about or encouraged about
and if you're like hey sleep over you
know super bowl sleep or hangover all
that that's real i get that but the the
best thing they got going for them to me
mike is the schedule we just put up
there you know you look at their first
five weeks
and you go
cardinals jets giants eagles dolphins i
can sit there and not blink at eye and
go they're clearly going to be the best
team on the field for four out of the
first five games of the year and the
eagles game is going to be at home in
san francisco so you know they have a
chance here why are you saying four out
of five they're the best team in five
hours you're right five out of five i'm
just saying that's one where i could go
okay if somebody wanted to argue it's a
little bit of a toss-up or whatever but
i could just say no doubt they're
clearly better than the cardinals the
jets the giants and the dolphins you
know
football hey the eagles are close but
yeah they're not you're right the the
49ers are more talented than the eagles
so they have a chance here to really set
themselves up early
and kind of regain that confidence and
mojo they had last year to where maybe i
think it lessens that super bowl
hangover to a degree
they've got those back-to-back games at
metlife stadium against the giants and
the jets they're coming to the
greenbrier down the road from me here in
west virginia you think your buddy
kyle's going to invite me to go down and
hang out with him no he's not going to
invite you
i can tell you that
maybe if i call him and beg him to let
you go down there maybe he'll let you go
down there but uh that's interesting too
because you know i didn't know if that
was going to be allowed in the nfl this
year just because of course the current
environment and i i know there's
that's what teams want to do this day
and age it's too much to travel back and
forth and do that in a six day period it
wears your team out uh so i was
interested to hear that nonetheless mike
he told me last year after week two when
they finished off the first two games of
the season staying on the east coast he
said look we've done it both ways guys
are dead if we go back and forth and
back and forth he said today before they
started that game against the bengals
that they won handily they were bouncing
off the walls yeah so it's smart it's a
sacrifice especially in a pandemic it's
a sacrifice to be away from the family
it's a sacrifice to be away from home
it's a calculated risk they'll set up a
mini bubble at the greenbrier and do
their best to keep everyone
covered free but uh it works when it
comes to that second game the first game
is the first game it doesn't matter
you're flying from california for the
first game it's that second game where
you get the advantage and i think
last they did it twice last year and
they were 2-0 in the second game they
had baltimore which they lost in the
first game of their second trip back but
they beat the saints
right after that's right i forgot they
did that in florida they stayed in
youngstown i think for one and in
florida for the others
it's smart it's smart and it works and
the nfl had strongly urged teams to go
home after games but uh the way kyle
explained it yesterday they've gotten
the approval or at least he hasn't heard
they haven't heard no and they're great
they're they're close enough to it that
the plans have to be in motion for it to
work all right let's talk about running
back yeah on this team yeah because look
if you if you play fantasy football you
prefer to have a a workhorse like a
christian mccaffrey a derek henry a guy
that you know is going to emerge
i look at raheem moster tevin coleman
jerick mckinnon i don't know who it's
going to be i think it depends on what
game it is right we of course raheem
mostert had the huge nfc championship
game and relatively disappeared in the
super bowl so who do you think of those
three emerges as the guy if any of them
do yeah i don't know if it'll be any
like clear-cut like oh man this guy
rushed for 1400 yards this year for this
offense no i don't first off you know i
think between kevin coleman and raheem
mostert they have a very similar skill
set so a lot of the times i think
they're just the 49ers will go with the
hot hand there as far as like ooh you
know this guy's got it today you know
he's seeing the holes he's seeing the
cut back lanes whatever his legs are
fresh so i i still think raheem mostert
i'll say
gets a little more carries than tevin
coleman but i don't think it's going to
be anything drastic to where we're going
to go like oh this is terrell davis for
you know mike shanahan and the broncos
back in the day no i don't and then you
know the jarrett mckinnon thing of
course with his injury history and all
that i think he'll be worked in slowly
but more than anything he has been
brought in there for the pass game
itself and i think that's where he'll
make a mark a little bit like we've
talked about with sean payton and joe
mixon and alvin kamara the last few days
shannon hands the west coast offense he
was there with me in tampa bay he
understands how to use the back out of
the backfield in the pass game and i
think that's where jared mckinnon will
make his mark for the offense
i would suggest in your fantasy football
leagues considering a late round flyer
on jerick mckinnon they gave him a ton
of money a couple of years ago when he
became a free agent it was a stunning
amount it was a huge investment but he
fits what they do and we haven't seen
him for two years out of sight out of
mind times two with the torn acl
suffered in late august of 2018 and then
the complications last year had to do it
again he's healthy and i think he could
be a factor in that offense kind of like
the guy that we're not thinking about
now there's always those guys we're not
thinking about them now and oh crap by
the time we get to halloween we're like
why weren't we thinking about that yeah
no i i hear you i could see that
certainly being the case you know
definitely you know the wide receiver
position them getting healthy those are
something we got to watch here you know
brandon ayoub the first rounder he's
been banged up debo samuel is coming
back from a broken foot can he play week
one you know that's what i worry about
early in the year is just having viable
big time options there i know shanahan's
awesome at getting people open but the
biggest thing is they still got george
kittle and you know what is another one
really underrated signing of the
offseason where guy's got a big injury
history i know that but when he's
healthy he's amazing is jordan reed
jordan rita tight end too
i mean if he can just not get a
concussion
he is special and shanahan knows how to
expose that part of the field to get
guys like kittle and jordan read the
football to where that could add another
dimension to their offense this year
that we don't think about
like a jerick mckinnon that's why i'm
bringing it up so it's really rare
that a team goes to the super bowl and
you look at them and you go damn
they didn't really get ravaged because
super bowl teams always get ravaged in
salary cap right or with the free agency
where everybody's like we want the
players that played in the super bowl
they must have been great that didn't
really happen to them they lost to
forrest buckner but we're very fortunate
to get a number 14 or 15 pick and javon
kinlaw to come right in and play that
position and i don't know if you won't
miss a beat but he's still really damn
good and that's pretty amazing that they
accomplished all that yeah and and they
had to do it because there's going to be
only so many dollars to go around
they've already paid d4 they know what
it's going to take to to get nick bose
especially now that joey's at 27 million
a year by the time nick comes due for
his new contract it's going to be north
of 30 million a year the pandemic will
be over by then we hope the
coffers will be restored and replenished
and the 49ers are going to have to pay
him big money and i think they got ahead
of that knowing that if you pay buckner
how are you ever going to be able to pay
bo so boast is the guy that they need to
make the center piece of the defense
let's talk about the centerpiece of the
offense before we go best case worst
case jimmy garoppolo earlier this week
we drafted potential first-time mvps and
and i went with jimmy g because if it
all works well and they end up with the
one seed and he plays well and he
responds well to the the threat that he
had to deal with back in march when kyle
shanahan was flirting with tom brady you
could become you could blossom into you
could grow into an mvp
what do they need him to do this year
just nuts and bolts what does he need to
do because we saw what happened in the
playoffs he freaked out kyle shanahan
when he when he threw what could have
been his third interception although
although uh eric kendricks didn't make
the play on the ball to pick it off they
went to run the ball and then they
stayed with run the ball the next week
he was bob griese in the nfc
championship game what do we need to see
from jimmy g this year well i think you
know you kind of just hit it like that's
the first thing just like
bonehead moments
okay that that would be the first thing
and yeah that was a little bit of a
theme throughout the playoffs where yeah
it wasn't sure if we could trust jimmy
garoppolo and you know to make the right
decision
not throw into a crowd so i think that
would be one thing i'd look at and not
that that was a consistent thing through
the year
but you know there was a lot of games
too where you could go back and look at
it and go oh the 49ers won but i could
show you periods of the game where i go
uh look jimmy's a little shaky here you
know shanahan called some screenplays
and some other things to be real
creative to kind of jump start him and
then they ended up winning the game we
kind of forgot about well like oh man
jimmy garoppolo was actually really
shaking in the first half but the second
half ended up so smooth it kind of
erased our memory of that so i would
just say consistency
and the other thing i would say is
improved aggressive type throws whether
that's you know deep post down the
middle in the super bowl but just more
plays like that throughout the year he
is not the best deep ball thrower and to
me if they can get that aspect of his
game a little bit better along with
maybe throwing some comebacks on the
outside and things like that that that
offense will be you know you won't be
able to defend it because shanahan's so
creative of what he does already it's
very hard they make you defend the whole
field but then if he could just add some
natural physical gifted power throws to
it uh i think that takes an offense to
the other to another level
and let's just say this but for
something something wasp and everything
that happened after that's right seven
minutes left in the super bowl jimmy
garoppolo is the guy who's cracking open
the tiny little humidor earlier this
week and opening up the super bowl ring
to go along with the super bowl mvp
trophy probably because he would have
been the mvp of the super bowl they
would have been the super bowl champions
and we'd feel very differently about
jimmy garoppolo
regardless
of the missed throw to emmanuel sanders
in the championship moment he wouldn't
even had to do it he would have already
had the hay and the barn he did
everything he already had to do with the
10-point lead to win the super bowl and
patrick holmes came back and took it
away all right best case worst case what
when the super bowl lose the super bowl
well yeah yeah well best case is win the
super bowl of course yeah i mean i think
this is one of the i think this is
arguably them and the ravens have the
best roster and team in football i mean
i know you got kansas city number one
and i probably put kansas city number
one too because they got that one guy
that i think even though they're less on
their roster
because of him i put them above them and
i think that's probably what you did too
uh so yeah win the super bowl worst case
uh again i don't i don't seven seed you
know that's that's really that's where i
look at it i just look at them and go
man offensive line damn good defensive
line damn good linebackers receivers
running backs i mean there's not a lot
to dislike about the team i just can't
see them falling too far off here yeah
best case win the super bowl worst case
one and out one done because they have
to go on the road in the playoffs not
that they may have to go into a stadium
with fans actually there but they go on
the road in the playoffs they don't and
here's the other thing too
i don't know if they've announced no
fans all year long i'll be surprised if
they have any fans at all this year at
home
even if they get the one seat again
those playoff games are not going to be
as easy as they were because the cr if
the crowd's not there it's going to take
a little something away from it i think
with the presence of george kittle the
49ers are situated to get the fire lit
under them every game because he will do
it himself he'll personally be the one
pulling the court on the lawnmower but
still i could see not winning the
division five seats six seed seven seed
go on the road lose in the first round
of the playoffs that's the worst case
scenario i think they'll make the
playoffs the question is will they be
positioned to get back in position to
have a shot at winning the super
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports